Annie can you come tell me if my heads
cut off
[Music]
this is the new sour patch kids cereal I
know candy for breakfast
no it's harp it's it's candy you can't
buy this in stores or at least I could
know we're in LA at least listed on the
website for this whatever the brand is
is this is a guy that didn't want you to
masturbate
was it Kellogg or post that didn't want
you to master Kellogg okay so post loves
masturbation but this has nothing to do
with miss Siri you can't get this in
stores yet I had to order this online
through some obscure website called
Amazon I have not read reviews about
this I have not watched other people
consume this product I have only used my
imagination to think about what this
could taste like and I've built up a lot
of expectations about what it could be
and I'm gonna see if it matches those
expectations in any way shape or form
and if it does then I give nothing but
if it doesn't then I get nothing
right down to drink and then I never
drink it so if I need to wash the taste
out of my mouth if it's bad but if it's
good then it's good so haha proper
cereal box opening etiquette is I have
no idea go at it like a cannibal though
I didn't like someone who hasn't eaten
in 30 days Ferhat actually someone who
hasn't eaten real food besides cereal in
30 days okay I immediately have a
problem I don't know if that will focus
in any way shape or form I'll take a
picture later just to give you a
detailed shot of this actually no I
could I can do this other I'm gonna move
the camera no I'm a professional so
that wait for it there is that that
right there that there zoom that doesn't
look necessarily like a Cabbage Patch
Kid but it's close
I guess finger for scale it's tiny
though this is not Cabbage Patch Kids
sighs this is itty bitty this is the
teensiest weensy little thing I've ever
seen and I've seen some teensy-weensy
things hey I look at myself in the
mirror every morning
maybe I wasn't talking about my goodness
my snowsuit didn't so I ate one you
probably couldn't see cuz it was just
zoomed in on this gap of my chest but I
ate one I wanted even now I realize how
little fanfare I put into that initial
conclusions sour in a cereal is very
weird I imagine that when I mix it with
the milk it's gonna make it seem like
that milk has been spoiled and if it
doesn't I don't know if it's gonna be
pleasant now here's the thing about me
you need to know this about me it's very
important there's rule number one about
learning about mark you plier Fischbach
I like sour things I like sour things
too much I like sour things to the point
where I make my mouth bleed from the
acid what makes sour things sour now I'm
gonna look at this and if I don't see
acids on here I know I'm not gonna
really like it the same way that I like
Osetra Kassadin that's the baseline sour
stuff that's that's baby sour level
stuff but that's still sour now I don't
know if that's in normal cereal dub
okay you got your blue yellow kinda
orange there is a difference between
yellow and orange there that's orange
that's yellow that's red and of course
green which we already saw what we don't
really care about so you got all your
Cabbage Patch Kids here kind of cool I
guess I don't know I'm all about real
crap cereals a me a mine friend no it's
fine I don't care
no it's fine oh okay let's go here this
is usually how I eat cereal anyway
that's it I'm already down I'm already
down I'm already down wait no you you
have to say you are already standing and
I get to say I'm art I'm still gonna
stay like this you won't trust him wait
no my other box I can't tell a
difference between the different flavors
I'm all for crap cereals I think I said
that already but my crap cereals of
choice are usually like cinnamon toast
crunch which has a sweetness to it but
not really a sour
I like Captain Crunch but that makes my
mouth bleed for other reasons you take
two bowls of Cap'n Crunch
you won't have teeth something about
just erodes the insides of your mouth
and I don't know if it's necessarily a
sour thing I think it's just because
they put rocks in it and everyone knows
Mohs hardness scale teeth fall low on
Mohs hardness scale or high I'm not sure
but whatever they put in Captain Crunch
that's high on Mohs hardness scale if
you don't know Mohs hardness scale that
is the scale very scientific and
definitely still accurate in 2019 that
says that whatever number of hardness
that thing is the only thing that can
scratch it is something of equal or
higher number of Mohs mores more Mohr's
hardness so maybe the milk is gonna like
have a reaction to this I don't know I'm
not gonna take it dries
yes I have to now now see I don't really
like taking a dry spoonful of anything
let alone cereal it wasn't like it was
unpleasant it's just that I in all of my
years of eating cereal which are many I
might be an expert at it it's never been
sour and it's not anything like a lot of
sour it's like a little bit it's like
teensy tiny amount of sour do you want
to close up I guess I mean like it's not
bad
the appeal of Sour Patch Kids for some
weirdos is that they are sour and then
sweet which goes for anything that's
sour because it's only the coating
that's sour except for warheads I guess
those are sour all the way through I
think but either way like usually its
surface coating stuff so it's not hard
to coat the surface of something like
this with something sour make it look
roughly like a Sour Patch Kid and then
it'll be sweet because it's got so much
sugar in it that you'll get diabetes
instantaneously but I will add milk
whole milk which is the only milk that
exists everything else is water my
finger okay
first bite bad didn't like milk didn't
help it made it go down smoother didn't
help kind of getting that kind of like
is this milk spoiled question in my mind
not good not great but it's not enough
of bad to stop me from keep going those
are words
[Music]
wait there's no there's a mad lib
there's a mad lib Amy there's a mad lib
the other pen where are the pens could
you bring me one wait wait wait no give
me an attitude dirty place please all
right fine
Wyoming lay by myself at time I'm not
I'm not reading the mad look itself I'm
just like pulling things out time 8:21
p.m. now raw Rock adjective smoky now
gonad adjective hasty of herb smack what
no no verbal smack known hemorrhoid just
one hemorrhoid adjective Spartan no not
Spartan sparse sports verb adjective say
me number ah 3 million do ordered wanna
do okay alright guys this is gonna be
great yeah alright you wake up in a
dirty wyoming at 8:26 p.m. in the
morning you get up and accidentally trip
over your rock but find your footing
when you hold on to the smokey gonad
this is gonna be a tasty day you smack
downstairs to the kitchen because it's
time for the most important meal of the
day breakfast bill you get your
hemorrhoid oh and a spoon all the proper
equipment as you pour your sparse sour
patch kids cereal it smoosh all over the
kitchen floor
turns into a zany mess luckily 3 million
222 of the sour patch kids still made it
into the bowl wahoo
it's gonna be a sweet day anyway my
cereal is now soggy holds up the crunch
[Music]
my favorite part about sterile is the
activities that's a pretty good activity
but the problem is this activity isn't
designed to share like you can't have
friends over and they look at the back
of the cereal be like oh I can still do
this they can kind of laugh at what you
put in here but it won't exercise their
brain at all but then again if you have
this cereal you're not gonna have any
friends it's not that it's bad it's that
I don't like it the problem is this is
probably aimed at people that like sour
things but there is very few people that
like sour things more than I do and I do
not like this cereal there are so many
other cereals that are a better
experience overall than eating of this
cereal here ambitious idea very
unpleasant IKEA I will keep eating it
like I will eat probably another bowl I
will probably finish this box but that's
because I hate myself and not
necessarily that I'd like it I am so
lazy and desperate that I would rather
eat cereal that I don't enjoy then
actually think about what I'm eating
[Music]
yeah yeah that was um that was not good
I don't understand why that was the way
that it was I don't know whose pitch
made this into a reality
hmm maybe it's growing on me oh I tried
it you can still track for yourself like
I recommend anything don't take my word
on it
I am oftentimes an idiot but I don't
like it as a sour candy connoisseur I
don't like this but that doesn't mean
that I wouldn't eat it so I give this a
bite the head off first out of attempt
because you want to just get it over
with
don't make it suffer like your job is
just to eat this bowl of cereal you got
to eat it so you can go to school or you
can go to work or
you can go to an early grave whatever
way just bite that off that's ridic so
thank you everybody so much if you want
to see me review more serials
I know humming the comments or something
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye bye
well that's content